من عمان ينضم الينا عمار عمار المسؤول
الاقليمي لليونسيف في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا سيد عمار اهلا وسهلا بك ما
هو التقييم اليونسيف ايضا الان الى اثار
هذا الزلزال والدمار الذي خلفه
ضحايا نتمنى الشفاء العاجل للمصابين طبعا
يعني الا ان الاضرار كتير كبيره وكانت
تبعاتها على جميع الاشخاص في في سوريا
وكذلك في تركيا وخاصه على الاضواء الاطفال
وتشير تقييمات الاوليه ان الاضرار التي
لحقت بالمرافق مثل المدارس والمرافق
الصحيه ومرافق المياه وتخزين المياه واسعه
النطاق وهناك العديد من الاشخاص الذين
كمان والاولاد والاطفال الذين تركوا
منازعوا منازلهم خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه
والان يقيمون في اماكن مؤقته حيث في
الشوارع او تحت الجسور او في بعض المدارس
وياتي كل هذا بينما الاجواء الجويه
القارصه البروده هناك امطار هناك ثلوج
فبالتالي الوضع الانسان سيء جدا فيما
يتعلق بالاشخاص المتضررين من الزلزال
قامه واحصائيات حول الاطفال
ربما الذين تضرروا كانوا ضمن الضحايا
المصابين الذين فقدوا عائلاتهم حتى لا
جراء هذا الزلزال سيد عمار ليس هناك
احصائيات دقيقه لكن اعتقد ان عدد الاطفال
المتضررين من جرحى او الذين للاسف لقوا
حتفهم تقدر بالمئات لم يكن بالالاف لذلك
من اهميه كمان الاشاره الى اهميه طبعا
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله كما الشرطه
السابقا الاشخاص الاطفال هم اكثر عرضه
طبعا
في صدمه من حيث الزلزال الهزات الارتداديه
بالاضافه الى ذلك الى الظروف الجويه في
اماكن غير اقامتهم فبالتالي يجب ان يكون
هناك عمل سريع فيما يتعلق بالاحتياجات
الانسانيه لمتطلبات الاهالي والاطفال
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالصحه النفسيه الى اي
مدى تستطيعون الان
عمار ضمن يعني اليونيسيف يعني التعامل مع
هذه التداعيات تلبيه الاحتياجات الاساسيه
الان للمتضررين من الاطفال وكذلك العائلات
المشردين يعني التامين الغذاء توفير ماوى
لهم كيف تتعاملون مع هذا الواقع المؤلم
طبعا يعني الاحتياجات الانسانيه كتير
كبيره
والجلسه منذ الساعات الاولى كانت موجوده
على الارض لتقييم الاحتياجات الانسانيه
بالتعاون مع الافرقه
واستطعنا كمان ان نقوم
بالاستجابه لبعض الاحتياجات الانسانيه
العاجله من ضمنها الامدادات الجراحيه
المتخصصه وغيرها من الملاكم من المواد
الاستهلاكيه الطبيه التي تم توفيرها الى
بعض المستشفيات بالاضافه الى ذلك اعاده
توزيع فرق الصحه والتغذيه المتناقله التي
تدعمها اليونيسف في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
من حيث التغذيه كمان كتير الموضوع لانه
بتعرف الاشخاص الذين تركوا بيوتهم ليس لهم
اي مكان
ممكن يتركوا اغراضهم اكلهم تركوا اموالهم
فبالتالي يجب من حيث التغذيه اليونسف
ستقوم بتوفير حزمه كامله من البسكويت على
الطاقيه مع شركائنا كمان هناك تنسيق مع
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي بشان توفير
الوجبات الساخنه وكذلك في ايضا هناك
تتعلق بالتقييم السريع فيما يتعلق بموضوع
المياه الصالحه للشرب تعرف انت سيدي
الكريم ثم يتعلق بالغزل الارضيه ممكن يصير
في تشويقكات او في الشبكات نقل المياه مع
وجود الكوليرا في سوريا التي بدا في شهر
سبتمبر 2022 ممكن يكون امام ازمه انسانيه
جديده كمان مستجده ان لم يتم معالجتها
بشكل سريع فهناك تقييم فيما يتعلق
بالمناطق الاكثر تضررا للشبكات المياه
واليونيسف ستقوم بشكل عاجل ايضا بتوفير
الوتر تكن
الكميات عبر عبر صهاريج مخصصه للمياه
بينما يتم فحص الشبكات امدادات المياه
للتاكد من سلامتها او اذا حاجه الى تاهيل
والصيانه ستقوم بدعم مثل هذه الاعمال
بالاضافه الى النشاطات اخرى وتقوم بها
خاصه مع الاطفال مع من تتواصلون الان سيد
عمار ما هي الجهات او الهيئات التي يقوم
اليونيسيفر الان بالتواصل معها لتوفير هذه
الحزمه من المساعدات في يعني مجالات
مختلفه
مع جميع الافرقه الموجودين نتعامل مع
السلطات مع الاشخاص الموجودين مع السلطات
المحليه مع شركائنا المحليين ايضا من
منظمات الاستجابه
من المنظمات المجتمع المدني فبالتالي يعني
علاقتنا مع الجميع لحتى نستطيع ان نقوم في
اسرع وقت بالوصول الى الاشخاص المتضررين
يعني لانه مثل ما شايف مثل ما عم نشوفها
بالاخبار من حيث الوقائع على الميدان انه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه عاجله فبالتالي
التنسيق على هذا المستويات مستمر لحتى
نتمكن ما يقوم بعملنا ونوصل للاشخاص
الاكثر تضررا بسرعه ونستطيع ان نلبي
احتياجاتهم ابقى معي سيد عمار فقط تشير
الى هذه الصور التي وصلتنا الان لوصول
فرقه من الجنود الفرنسيين ربما نعم كما
كما كما وصلتني المعلومات عن قوات فرنسيه
تصل الان الى تركيا ضمن حزمه المساعد او
الفرق التي تصل ايضا من فرنسا من ضمن فرقه
الدفاع المدني الفرنسيه
لمساعده الحكومه التركيه
والجهات ذات العلاقه في اجلاء الضحايا
والعالقين اعود اليك سيد عمار كنت تتحدث
عن جهات داعمه ربما تم التواصل مع عليه
المساعده هل هناك توقيت زمني محدد يمكن
الحديث عنه لوصول هذه المساعدات
العمل مستمر على مدار الساعه انا باكد لك
هيدا الموضوع وبعض المساعدات بدات يعني
بالوصول الى الاشخاص المتضررين ومساعدات
اكبر ستكون في طريقها ايضا الى الاشخاص
الذين هم بحاجه في الساعات وعلى الايام
المقبله بدي شير هنا لنقطه كتير مهمه يعني
انه
في عام 2023 وقبل الزلزال يعني كان هناك
15.3 مليون شخص في سوريا بحاجه الى
مساعدات انسانيه بما في ذلك سبع ملايين
طفل وخاصه في مجال الحمايه والتعليم
والمياه والصحه وما الى هنالك وياتي
الزلزال الانديفوار فاقم الازمات
الانسانيه التي يعاني منها الاشخاص
والاطفال في سوريا فبالتالي نطلب من
الجميع الاشخاص القادرين على تقديم
المساعده لمنظمه الانسانيه لمنظمه
اليونيسف انه يقوموا بهذا الواجب خاصه انه
اليونسف طلبه سنه 2023
328 مليون دولار لبرمجها الانسانيه في
سوريا
وهناك عجز في من هذه المبلغ من قبل
المانعين
فبما ذلك الان مع تفاقم الاحتياجات
الانسانيه بعض الزلزال المربع الذي حصل
فبالتالي هذا هو الواقع وهذا اللي عم
بيصير على ارض الميدان لكن نحن ما زلنا
مستمرين يعني عملنا الانساني فيما يتعلق
بمساعده الاشخاص واهم المنتضررين من
الاجهزه يختلف الامر او التقييم لحجم
الدمار بالنسبه اليسار هذا الزلزال حتى
الان بين المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام
السوري والمناطق الاخرى ربما التي فيها
المساء كما يقول الكثير من المراقبين اكبر
واعظم المناطق التي لا تسيطر عليها قوه
النظام
يعني بعتقد انا ان الماسات صراحه اي طفل
اللي احنا بنخسره هو خساره للجميع بغض
النظر عن اي منطقه كان عايش فيها وين
بينتمي اليها في مناطق القاطعه النظام او
الفئه المناطق الاخرى لكن بالنسبه لنا
الاهم انه عم نشوف الموجود من خلال
التقييمات انه الاحتياجات الانسانيه كبيره
الاحتياجات الانسانيه موجوده وخاصه لدى
الاطفال ويجب ان يكون هناك استجابه سريعه
لتلبيتها بغض النظر عن اي مكان موجودين في
في سوريا ما هي الاحتياجات الان التي
تعملون على تقديمها للمتضررين
طبعا احنا في المقام الاول عم نتطلع على
موضوع الصحه على موضوع طبعا الصحه النفسيه
والصحه الجسديه فيما يتعلق بالتغذيه فيما
يتعلق بحمايه الاطفال الاطفال الذين
تتفرقوا بسبب ايضا الزلزال اعاده
جمعهم عدويهم فيما يتعلق بامدادات
الجراحيه العاجله للمستشفيات طبعا لحتى
تقوم بعلاج الاشخاص الجرح من الزلزال
توزيع ايضا فرقه الصحه والتغطيه المتنقل
التي تدعمها اليوسف في المناطق الاكثر
تضررا من حيث التغذيه ايضا سيتم توفير
كميات مخصصه هي من البسكويت عالي الطاقه
هذه مع شركائنا منسق مع برنامج الاغذيه
العائله العالمي بشان توفير الوجبات
الساخنه وكمان في قطاع التعليم
نقوم بتقمه طبعا بالتقييم النتائج هناك
الاف الاسر التي نزحت التي تقيم في العدد
كبير من المدارس يعني على الاقل شيء
تم استخدامها كما ومن من حيث الاهالي ايضا
ننظر الى الاحتياجات الناشئه عن وجود التي
تتطلبها التي يتطلبها هؤلاء النازحين
واطفالهم شكرا جزيلا لك المسؤول الاقليمي
لليونيسيف في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا من عمان عمار عمار